on many occasions i made some quite
powerful people very angry but you don't
shame them into changing their behavior
though do you
i'm commissioner for human rights and my
mandate is very clear
europe has almost nothing to teach the
rest of the world about human rights
does it
this is not black and white this is not
easy the council of europe has
issued its latest verdict on human
rights and democracy in europe
and it makes unpleasant reading europe's
democratic environment and institutions
it says are in mutually reinforcing
decline
we talk a lot about democracy and human
rights on this program
and spend a good deal of time holding
politicians to account for actions
that appear to endanger those rights but
the situation is now so critical we've
decided to question a leading official
who's trying to protect human rights
about why that protection
is failing dunya miatovich is
commissioner for human rights at the
council of europe
and she joins me now from strasbourg
what is it that's gone
so spectacularly wrong
welcome to conflict zone thank you two
months ago you pressed the
emergency button on human rights in
europe you said 2020 had been
a disastrous year for those rights on
the continent
one of the bleakest assessments to be
heard for a long time do you think
anybody
is listening to your warning
well i hope so um it is
something that is affecting us all no
matter
which part of the world and if this is
not a moment
for all governments in europe and beyond
uh to take a long hard look uh in the
mirror
and realize how important it is that we
move forward
uh in a different way than we've been
moving
uh until now before this unprecedented
time
that we are all uh facing but
i wonder if people are listening because
plenty of your warnings in the past have
fallen on deaf ears
one example the issue of migrant abuse
in hungary
as far back as 2019 you said this
needed to be addressed as a matter of
urgency
nothing was done the hungarians
continued pushing back
migrants across their border with serbia
my question is
why do you think you lack the personal
authority to change
minds of people who do these things who
commit these violations
or is hungary a lost cause
well i would not say that the hungary is
lost cause first of all because of
hungarians because
of people that rely on the protection of
the convention
when it comes to my personal uh
influence and the impact
the time will tell i cannot change the
governments
i cannot play to be an opposition uh but
i can use something that is the most
i would say powerful tool uh in my
toolbox as commissioner which is my
voice
giving my voice to voiceless making sure
that uh human rights violations are
documented
and this is something that is already i
would say
extremely important the impact
can be measured in different ways but
many of us in different international
organizations have been saying for years
uh
about hungarian situation and also in
situation of many other countries that
are moving in a very
bad direction if i can say so freedom of
media for example comes to my mind
already in 2010 in a different position
i warned about so-called media package
and i said this is going to hit us as a
boomerang
and this is happening right now
nevertheless
we should not give up we should continue
warning and using
all the tools that we have at our
disposal but ultimately it will be a
decision
of hungarians and also the government
that should comply with the
international
rule of law and standards well it isn't
just hungary is it there are
plenty of states that are involved in
these violations
um you often hear the claim that human
rights must be sacrificed for the sake
of protecting
national or european boundaries what do
you
tell those governments which which
advance that argument
i strongly disagree with this i think
this is a wrong path
and wrong way particularly after
everything that europe as a continent
experienced in the last decades and uh
70 years ago when the organization of
the council of europe was
established this is not the way to
protect
multilateralism multilateralism
proved to be of extreme importance not
only for democratic countries but also
countries that are trying to move
towards some democratic
order as you know i come from sarajevo
from bosnia and herzegovina
and i know how it is important to move
forward
and recognize the international
issues at the same time of course
protecting culture
tradition but not using it uh as an
excuse not to protect human rights
this is wrong and because of this view
uh on many occasions i made some quite
powerful people very angry
which in a way is part of my
angry but you don't shame them into
changing their behavior though do you
well i try to shame them and name them
but then at the end you know it really
depends
on the government what they will do as i
said i cannot i'm not an opposition
a political opposition i'm commissioner
for human rights and my mandate is very
clear it was created by those states in
order to remind
uh it is quite i would say a young
institution
20 years since the establishment but
it's
also quite unique because it is
autonomous independent
and it is up to the commissioner to
decide in which direction to
draw the attention and to call for
respect of human rights of course i
agree with you
this is not black and white this is not
easy we would all like to see results
i understand commissioner i understand
but the key to the effective
functioning of the council is the
binding commitment
supposedly of member countries to
implement decisions
of the european court of human rights
that too
has been a significant failure hasn't it
your own figures show it as of january
this year
a staggering 45 percent of the leading
judgments from the court
finalized in the last 10 years have not
been
implemented that's a shocking figure
isn't it
it is shocking figure but at the same
time we also need to recognize that uh
many decision you know they were
implemented and there are states that
still
do honor their commitments uh
this is quite extraordinary uh what we
are facing at the moment
and here i can just mention cases that
are affecting people's lives
uh i can uh really uh refer to the case
of
osman cavalla uh who i visited in
silvery prison um
two years ago he's still uh in prison he
even though there is a judgment from the
european court of human rights
and turkish government is not
implementing this extremely important
judgment
uh navalny in russia
but these rulings are your most
important
tool for correcting injustice and
governments are throwing huge numbers of
them
in the bin and my question is
if if that doesn't work and that's your
major
lever your major mechanism for righting
wrongs
what have you got left um i think it's
and i would correct you there it's one
of the mechanisms of course
it is extremely important one i can
always uh
um present a third party intervention
uh like i did in many of the cases that
we already mentioned
but then it is ultimately you know with
the states and
also the committee of ministers of the
council of europe that is monitoring uh
execution of the judgments
of the european court of human rights
for me there are other tools
at my disposals bilateral discussions
but also
seeking access to prisons in order to
really try to understand the situation
that in some states is extremely
uh complex but i agree with you that the
execution of the judgments of the
european court of human rights is a key
uh and that is something that as the
organization
we need to to do more more needs to be
done on the political level
uh we need more you know uh governments
that are willing to
to name the states that are not uh
really um that are they
they they seem to be judgements they
seem to be in short supply those
governments
you you have pointed out that covet the
covet pandemic has accelerated the
decline
of democracy in europe with governments
acquiring special powers that have
served to erode the checks and balances
on them but this process has been
underway for a long time as you said on
april 21st commitment to upholding human
rights values
has been faltering all over the
continent for several years
so during those years there should have
been time to stop the slide no
why wasn't the intervention done much
much earlier when the pattern
was seen and identified well
that is a you know question of a million
dollar for all of us
uh to answer and also to ask ourselves
why are we facing this uh
situation now should the major powers
have done more should germany france uk
i mean they all claim to value human
rights should they have done more all of
the states
should have done more uh but when it
comes to human rights protection
i would say you know based on my career
and everything i did i see it not as
a sprint it is a
is a it is a marathon i would say it is
difficult
uh uh to to see results results require
time but i think that commitment is a
key here
and a lot of victims don't have time do
they dunya me out of it a lot of victims
are living in appalling conditions
appalling human rights abuses
with many um visiting uh many but there
are also results uh
only yesterday uh i i learned about
a decision by the czech
parliament to compensate roma women
that suffered sterilization in the 90s
which was part of my work and engagement
with the parliament and the government
justice is also very slow but it is
important that we see it at the end
and i agree with you there are many
victims there are many parts of
marginalized parts of the society
uh that are waiting for uh impact and
waiting for
their health for for the help from isn't
it
isn't it true commissioner that um
business in a way
is to blame for this faltering
commitment that you've spoken about
this idea for instance that germany
always pushes
change through trade you get the trade
but in terms of human rights nothing
changes does it
look at the deals with china and rough
russia no
leverage on human rights whatsoever
this was especially true of the
controversial nordstream 2 gas deal
with russia no human rights
considerations were allowed to get in
the way of that were there
this is this is a lost opportunity isn't
it
to push human rights of course
each time uh human rights are not in the
center
of any kind of discussions uh we fail
um and we move uh backwards but
at the same time i think this should
also be assigned to all of us working
in human rights area not to uh
really uh be um
in a way ignorant to these happenings of
course we do follow everything but
my work and my mandate uh gives me
you know many opportunities to raise
these questions
uh with the governments with the
civil society in many of the states and
for me
uh dialogue is a key as well but also at
the same time you know acquire diplomacy
but the dialogue has to get somewhere
the dialogue has to get somewhere
doesn't it and and looking at your
report
europe has almost nothing to teach the
rest of the world about human rights
does it
you said in contemporary europe human
rights defenders
are killed abducted jailed harassed
the space for civil society dwindles
democratic institutions
are dismantled independent judges
removed
journalists are silenced by pointing to
all that
you've effectively demolished the idea
that europe is some kind of
beacon of human rights haven't you it
isn't it isn't anymore it doesn't
deserve the time i would
i would still say that it is uh there
are many things that we should not
uh take for granted and forget that you
know millions of of people have become
free from oppression uh poverty
free to live the life they want so it's
not
uh as black as white and and you just
portrayed it
europe looks much better 15 years of
steady
decline of observance of human rights
and democratic principles
that's nothing to be proud of is it no
that's nothing to be proud of but as i
say there are still
uh examples of governments uh
you know really accepting refugees doing
great things for for human rights
you mentioned russia let's take a state
that doesn't appear to be committed to
those
rights um like all member countries
russia agreed to be bound by the rulings
of the european court of human rights
but in the case of the opposition leader
alexei navalny which you mentioned
earlier
russia has clearly flouted the orders of
the court hasn't it the court said in
february navalny should be
temporarily released from jail because
the government couldn't provide
sufficient safeguards for his life and
health russia's
justice minister called the ruling
unenforceable
and threw it in the bin where does that
leave you well this is a clear
disregard of human rights and
international
obligations navalny case uh is a
emblematic case uh this also shows that
beneath you know there are many more
problems like lack of independent
judiciary in russia
uh human rights abuses in in chechnya
lack of investigation uh repression of
descent and harassment of human rights
defenders
so it's not just navalny navalny is just
one case
uh where we see that russian federation
is completely disregarding the decision
of
the european court of human rights but i
still uh remain hopeful
uh that he will be soon free and uh
russia will show uh that there are uh
important uh one uh member of the
council of europe
i wonder what your hope is based on
commissioner because the russian state
also called the court's ruling
blatant and gross interference in the
judicial affairs of a foreign state
now that one statement undermines the
whole basis on which countries belong to
the council of europe doesn't it
the fact is if the council does nothing
about this
then countless numbers of people in
russia and elsewhere
will conclude that you're simply not
capable of enforcing the requirements
of council membership and standing up to
tough and abusive
governments isn't that right not really
it is not that uh simple uh it is
up to the government to implement the
judgment it is up to the committee of
ministers
of the council of europe to push for the
execution of the judgment
uh we have to keep the dialogue with the
authorities
also in difficult uh situations and it
is not
because of difficulties that we uh give
up
on the contrary i think this is also a
moment for the council of europe
uh to do more than ever before uh and
with all the institutions and all the
mechanisms that we have at
our disposal i think at the end we will
succeed
but this cannot happen uh overnight at
the same time i completely agree with
you that
uh not executing judgments of the
european court of human rights is
unacceptable
and all the countries that are really uh
not
doing it should be uh called uh publicly
and uh really uh you know we should try
to do as much as we can
in order to uh continue pushing for the
release of people that are sitting in
jail and are innocent
commissioner unacceptable is is an
overused word
internationally isn't it it's normally
meant to um
cover things that we've already accepted
but wish we hadn't
um russia has faced credible allegations
of attempting to murder
not only alexei navalny but a former
intelligence officer sergey skripal and
his daughter in england in 2018
and they actually are accused of
murdering
another former officer alexander
litvinenko in london
in 2006. um
russia denies all these charges but
these are credible allocations and it
still has
its seat in the council odd isn't it
that despite these allegations from a
european
body it's still allowed to keep its seat
in a body that promotes democracy and
human rights why is that
why is that i mean this is not really
a question i can answer because not only
russia but
all the states are sitting in
international organizations they have a
seat in the security council at the un
the osce including council of europe
uh my role is not to make a judgment if
the state
should sit in um you know as a member or
not
uh this is definitely outside you know
my mandate but
what is it is in my mandate is to remind
those states to comply with the
commitments and
to honor the values uh and that they
agree
uh upon when they became members of
different
international organizations nobody
pushed russia
or forced russia to become a member of
the council of europe
or any other country why do we see
that not only russia but many other
countries are simply
ticking the box and saying we are proud
member of this and that organization
and not doing anything it's a it's a
huge question uh for
for all of us but this this club of
yours this this council of europe
uh the problem is it gives many
governments a cloak of respectability
that they don't deserve doesn't it
like as i said you know being a member
of of the club
uh you know it's uh honorable thing but
if you do not follow the rules
of the club then you know this is
something that should be
um exposed and the seat uh
in the council uh i think is important
to say
uh is to ensure protection of the
citizens not the governments uh we work
for
for uh the people excluding people uh
because
governments behave badly would leave
people without protection which is the
last thing i would like to see as
commissioner for human rights
engaging with the ordinary people
marginalized people is is a main issue
for me
you're doing a lot more monitoring than
protecting these days though
aren't you you're not you're not
protecting the people in turkey for
instance last year
nearly 26 000 people were in jail
awaiting trial on
terrorism charges that continue to be
widely
misused and used in fact to restrict
free expression and association
they're not protected no i mean they
you know you're wrong here uh you know
protection means much more than just
you know saying okay i'm just going with
a sword and i'm going to protect all
those people
no people in turkey do feel uh they are
protected
by my office and me personally they see
my office as an oasis where they can
complain
and you know seek protection and this
happened
on many occasions i was given access as
i already stated to prisons to see osman
cavalla
and ahmed al-than who is released now um
and i do try to engage with the turkish
government's
government on the issue of human rights
defenders and journalists and
numerous cases before the court
but it's not an easy task but at the
same time
it is honorable and it gives me even
more energy to to engage and to try
to help uh people helping one individual
can also change a lot uh in
any country but you rightly uh stated uh
previously that at the moment we do not
live
in a good time for human rights human
rights are neglected
pushed under the carpet by many
governments ultra-conservative groups
are targeting civil
society and human rights defenders and
this is a sad reality why are we facing
this
situation um as i already said it's a
question for the scholars
nevertheless we need to continue working
well it's also a question
um you can't just blame the governments
can you what about the people who put
them there
what happens when free elections empower
politicians who then take away
their rights what then what then well
the
the the question is also uh were the
elections always free and fair
uh it's not the case uh all the time uh
you have many reports from credible
international organizations
uh including parliamentary assembly of
the council of europe stating that
certain elections in certain states
were everything but not free and fair so
you
end up with the governments that want to
stay
forever neglect human rights and this is
something we should not allow
i have a mandate for 47 member states of
the council of europe and differences
are huge
but no state is immune to violations of
human rights
and documenting this and pointing out
and working together with people can
bring results not overnight
but the fact that but the fact is the
autocrats are winning aren't they
uh when you look back through the
centuries
it's repression that's the enduring
constant not democracy
and now that repression is back with a
vengeance and we have to face that fact
don't we
yes that's uh that's true but i would
not say that the
autocrats are be winning there are
examples
um and we should listen to different
voices in the society
uh but we should not uh use
uh those voices that are spreading lies
uh
fake news uh targeting human rights
defenders generally civil society
in order to to win uh votes we should
not
use this as a excuse for not doing
enough
but what i think is also important is
that
all international organizations should
use
the situation now and try to push
for changes by putting human rights in
the center of uh
i understand but but but very briefly if
you keep sounding the alarm bell
and nothing improves and it hasn't been
improving as we pointed out over the
last 15 years it's been a
steady decline the danger is that people
are going to stop listening
aren't they they're going to stop taking
you seriously
there was a steady decline but i
disagree that there was no progress and
there were no
issues related to rights that were
improved in many member states
uh if you look at the situation with
lgbti community
when it comes to women's rights i mean
we are still fighting the struggle is
present
but the situation changed for better uh
if you look at um roma communities in in
many states
they were examples of of uh success
and moving forward so it's not just you
know
completely uh you know really grim
situation that we need to
just uh accept this and say okay we
failed no we did not
all right i'm afraid we're out of time
thanks very much for being with us on
conflict zone thank you thank you
thank you very much
[Music]
you